All right so here's the mixed strategy.
The mixed strategy is
that everyone just dares,
chooses to dare with
probability one-third.
>> Really?
>> Yeah,
that works out to be a Nash equilibrium.
We'll leave it as an exercise to the
reader to convince themselves of that,
but it does actually
work out to be the case.
>> And so that means we both, okay,
we both dare with probably a third,
which means two-thirds
of the time we chicken.
So there's going to be some probability
that we both chicken, some probability
that I chicken and you don't,
some probably that you chicken and
I don't, and then the lowest
probability is we both dare, boom!
>> Right, so in fact, I'm glad you
said that, because that's exactly how
we would figure out how good
a strategy this mixed strategy is.
>> Right.
>> So, let's do this.
So, let me ask you a question.
What's the probability
that we both chicken?
>> Four-ninths.
>> And how do you get four-ninths?
>> I looked at your notes.
That's the problem with
being in the same place when
we're doing these recordings.
>> Well, I'm pretty impressed that
you can actually read my handwriting,
I'm pretty sure.
>> No, I cannot only not read it, but
my eyes are old enough that I can't read
it anyway even if you write it nicely.
So, no, what I did is, I took if
the probability of dare is a third,
then the probability of
chicken is two-thirds.
And we're independently choosing that,
so the probability that both of us
choose it is two-thirds times
two-thirds, or four-ninths.
>> So what's the probability
of one person chickening and
the other person daring,
in particular C, D?
>> C, D, so that's one-third times
two-thirds, which is two-ninths.
>> Mm-hm.
And by symmetry?
>> Nine-seconds.
Sorry, two-ninths.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then dare, dare would be
one-ninth because it's dare times dare.
>> Right.
>> And
let's just double check that four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Whoo-hoo!
Wait, no not one-third,
the bottom thing.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Okay.
And so, now we can figure out from
this what our expected, let's say,
my expected reward would be for
playing this Nash equilibrium.
>> Right, so
let's say you're player one.
So this is you.
So then if we do C, C, what is your,
actually you're the row.
What is your a payoff?
>> 6.
>> So,
we can just say 6 times four-ninths.
What's the payoff if you chicken out and
I dare.
>> 2.
And what's the payoff if you dare and
I chicken out?
>> 7.
>> And
what's the payoff if we both dare?
>> 0.
So we add all that up,
multiply these numbers, add them, and
what do we end up with?
>> You're asking me?
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
>> You're the one who can do arithmetic.
>> You're right, it's 4 and two-thirds.
>> Really?
>> Yeah, we just did that by
keeping the denominator the same.
So, that's 24 plus 4,
which is 28, plus 14, right?
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which is 42, plus 0,
42 over 9 is 4 and two-thirds.
>> This is actually pretty cool,
and the payoff is 4 and
two-thirds on average for you.
And by symmetry it's actually 4 and
two-thirds.
>> Which I like better than
both of us chickening out.
>> Right, both of you chickening out is-
>> No, no, sorry, sorry.
That's better.
I like better than me chickening out.
[LAUGH]
>> Right.
>> And then I'll only get two.
>> Right, and so actually doing this,
even though occasionally we will, well,
in the game we'll both die, but
of course we aren't going to die, we're
just going to get 0 utility because all
that other stuff doesn't really matter.
>> Okay.
>> We're going to do this.
This is actually pretty good, right,
this is a pretty good pay-off.
>> Okay, I agree with that.
>> In fact, for either one of us, if we
get in the short end of the stick for
the C,D,D,C,
this is actually better for us.
>> That's true, the worst of us,
or sorry, not the worst of us.
That doesn't sound right at all.
But the least fortunate of us is much
happier with this outcome than the C, D.
>> Right, and by the way, we're actually
happier with his outcome than if we had
uniformly randomly chosen between them.
>> And we're better off with this
outcome than if we had done C, D,
and then like split the winnings,
which would be 4 and-a-half.
>> Yeah, so it's the same thing as
doing half, or going by half, right?
It's 4 and-a-half, 4 and-a-half
is less than 4 and two-thirds.
Those are, in fact,
the same thing in this case.
>> Got it.
>> This is why it's
something like a third and
not something like a half.
So, that's pretty cool.
So, this seems like a pretty good win,
but
I'm going to claim
that we can do better.
>> Hm, okay.
>> Okay.
So, let's remember this 4 and two-thirds
and keep it around for a little while,
and let me try to convince you
that we're going to do better.
Okay?
>> Okay.